a little while ago on my YouTube
community feet I posted up the following
question summing up I get a number of
questions on the story in the comments
of my videos and a lot of these are the
same questions repeated each week so is
basically asking what law related
questions you'll have that may not be
covered in the game weren't very clear I
had a huge number of questions on the
hunters as expected but because there is
nothing official to go on with these
guys and there are already a number of
videos discussing potential theories
have left them out of this FAQ session
in order to focus on some of the other
aspects of the game I must note that the
majority for this is based on my own
interpretations of the game in the
direction of the story so more often
than not these aren't coming from the
writers and devs this is purely my
speculation from what I've seen in the
storyline up until now
this would probably be the most asked
question that I've been getting lately
sadly another review probably won't be
happy with the answer I'm going to give
I've actually had some very hostile
experiences when discussing this with
some people some of you might remember
me talking about this briefly in one of
my videos quite a while ago the agents
we took on at the release of the
division 2 are not related to our agents
from the original game I understand the
need people have to continue the story
immersed into the character if they
spent four years exploring the division
world worth but the reasons for us
having a new character is purely a
business decision with the release of
the sequel the developers didn't want
new players feeling like they were
handicapped if they hadn't played the
original game this was to be a new
chapter within the overall narrative of
the division I couldn't find links to
the exact state of the games that they
said this but the diffs explained that
our division one agent was also called
in to assist in Washington DC but is not
the same agent we play in the division 2
they went further to say that whatever
is happened to your first character is
up to your imagination it could be
possible that they died on their way to
DC well that maybe they're sitting there
in the White House alongside us they
could have even gone rogue enjoying the
black tusk ranks there is no hard
storyline for our old agents the best I
can give you is an article from the
Ubisoft website dated June 14th 2018 a
link will be in the description
this is a good question and it's
completely unanswered within the game or
accompanying texts but from the broken
door novel we see the importance of
marking Solanas rogue from their
accounts of Aurelio Diaz when he
second-guesses himself a number of times
after Ike Ronson lifts civilians to be
gunned down he shows that this isn't
something to be taken lightly but he
also talks about what I can do once is
marked as Rogue rogue agents have the
opportunity to hand themselves in and
discuss the charge against them of
course there is some risk of this as
division agents are given the power to
shoot first and ask questions later when
we look at how easy it is to become
marked as rogue particularly through
Isaac's protocol system and makes sense
if there's some sort of override system
but who controls us is anyone's guess
I'd say they were more likely to be
stripped of the u.s. HD gear and locked
up until a more senior agent can make
the call or perhaps at wrists on the
directors within one of the three shd
cos located through the center of the
country
if you wonder a little more detail on
the HD structure there should be a link
to a video on-screen
I love this question
some of you might remember a video
released a while ago titled has ancient
Kelso gone rogue after the release of
warlords of New York we found out that
it was in fact agent fail ow that has
turned it back on the division and
following this I was inundated with
comets telling me how wrong I was about
Kelso while they never state that any of
my crazy tinfoil hat theories are 100%
legit I admit I never saw the fail out
piece coming I still feel there is
something deal with Kelso she just feels
a bit off not just because she reminds
me of a couple of Bechet crazy
ex-girlfriends of head just that we
haven't seen all that she has to offer
to the story Kelso is so on that wears
her heart on his sleeve
I legitimately believe that we are seen
everything she is feeling upfront and
straight from her mouth sometimes a
multitude of feelings within a short
period of time but I think a time will
arrive when we all come against a face
to face this could be due to us leaving
the shd and leaving her behind or her
following president Ellis in one way or
another
I had to sum up this question but
basically it asked what has happened
with the teletran Inca now that we have
them we have the bioreactor we have the
antivirals why have we not heard how
this is going I recognize that this is
probably a little bit of a weak answer
but I believe that not enough time has
passed yet it could be easy to lose
track of the story timeline when
compared to the real world time it takes
to have these story updates released
look at the Division one a lot of us
played this for near four years but in
the story only a month or so it passed
by the time we managed to get into the
division to content only seven months
have passed since the events of the
dollar flow although we may not
physically see him on the DC map
I believe that training Co is in DC
starting work on the antivirals and that
we're likely to see an update on this
and future title updates or DLCs
by far one of my favorite characters of
the original game he added a certain
something to the dialogue that are quite
enjoyed in fact almost two years ago I
released a video talking about a story I
hate watching my own videos especially
ones that were released this long ago
but for this video I needed a recap the
cringe was real summing up I talked
about how Alessi was always one step
ahead with information he was able to
get it before the JTF and even the
division I speculated on whether he had
ties within the government or maybe he
had been in contact with Aaron Tina who
may have been feeding him information so
he could relay as theories out into the
public around the dollar flow the
government and the division but just as
things started getting really
interesting with the story he just
disappeared with the return to New York
in warlords of New York it didn't give
us a lot to go on with the story but he
does seem to have taken a full
360-degree on his opinion of the
division and listen here's the truth
people Benitez and the JTF would have
been [ __ ] without the division yes
it's time to check the skies from flying
bacon you heard me
the pigs are flying and I'm gonna have
to eat my words with a cytochrome sad
truth is directive 51 turned out to be
necessary
personally to me this feels like more of
an easter egg to feed him to the
nostalgia a lot of us have from the
first game I don't feel like this has
any significance to his overall story
but tell me have I missed any other
recordings from Blasi and Walid's of New
York have I just been blindly running
through the safe houses oblivious to any
radios that could have been playing or
is this just another did into the story
of Rick Alessi
well we all know from the introduction
to the original game that the dollar flu
has spread around the world we also find
out later that the United States was the
worst hit due to it being the origin of
the virus and the other countries having
a small amount of time to prepare and
quarantine individuals ahead of it
getting out of control from the broken
door novel we can see that the virus has
hit the country far and wide and that
most regions have fallen back to a
somewhat rudimentary state where people
are getting back to basics in order to
survive the division 2 story continues
on to talk more about the survival of
the people and the aftermath of this
biological attack the virus is still
there but it's slowly dying out it's
likely that the rest of the country is
running on the bare bones of society and
are dealing with their own versions of
the hostile factions that we're seeing
in New York and DC however for obvious
reasons the writers have chosen to keep
our attention on the more pressing
events like the fall of the Capitol and
the invading black task forces I have no
doubt that we'll be hearing more about
the rest of the country in upcoming
editions but for now we can only assume
that they are in a slightly less
vulnerable position than the epicenter
of the virus that we've been involved
with the rest of the world however seems
to be in a much better position than the
United States given the small window
they had to prepare they've managed to
be able to isolate the virus before it
was able to overwhelm them I actually
wouldn't be surprised if later additions
to the story showed a combination of
allies trying to help in other countries
wanting to take advantage of the current
situation who come together on the
continent to fight for the outcome of
the country and all that war fought an
American soil
three-part question or actual break this
down what are the rogue agents doing in
DC I'm actually in the middle of
potentially writing something up on this
one if this dam maintenance would finish
up soon
I'm telling you Australia New Zealand
get hit hard by the maintenance times
which makes sense I guess there's only
like 12 people who live down this into
the globe heavily summing this up kina
sent the rogue agents to Washington DC
this was confirmed by a number of
recordings between him and the Rogues
this also explains what we seen the
cleaners in DC as they were sent along
with them to assist this all seems to
have been part of his master plan or
legacy but I hope to touch base on this
a little bit further in an upcoming
video who was Barden Schaffer here's the
black tusk specialist unit leader he is
in command of the attack of the black
tusk on Washington DC with the task of
controlling the city and wiping out the
division as they are labeled as a rogue
agency although he isn't in command of
the full black tusk organization he is
in challenge of the black tusk that
we've been facing so far in the division
story where is president Ellis what is
his connection with the black tusk I'm
gonna reference yet another one of my
videos where I talk about the presidents
of the Dahl float it goes on to explain
how Ellis originally the Speaker of the
House was placed in the position of
president by the black tusk who were
involved in the elimination of at least
one of the presidents before him through
in-game recording so we can see that
Ellis has been contacted by the black
tusk and is now working for them the
black tusk has plans for president Ellis
that involves the new American Society
that they're attempting to establish it
would seem that Ellis has his own agenda
but at this stage we get to see what
this is but as far as location goes if I
had to guess I would say he's been kept
close possibly in a neighboring state to
Washington DC the black tusk Needham
close by for the next stage in their
plans but they also need to keep him at
a distance as the division have already
come close to capturing him a camp white
oak
the questions I chose was some of the
more upvoted that was submitted I'm
happy to do more of these of this
interest if you have any more random
questions regarding the division story
please post them in the comments and as
I can only tackle so many of them at a
time please give the thumbs up to the
ones you'd like to see me answer
I'll focus on these first other words
thank you very much for watching and
I'll catch you in the next one
Cheers
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]